okay so this is my updated version of my
eternal battle of good versus evil
and the process of mitosis versus
meiosis you know every year I teach this
lesson and students will sometimes mix
up a few stages so I hope this video
will help clarify so what the picture
shows is a cell going through the
process of mitosis a human cell has 46
chromosomes that is what we call the
diploid chromosome number and in the
process of mitosis a diploid cell with
46 chromosomes will divide into two
cells each of them also containing 46
chromosomes well that's a little
different when we compare and contrast
with meiosis in the picture we see a
cell starts very similar when it goes to
the process of meiosis a cell a human
cell will start with 46 chromosomes but
through the process of meiosis that 46
chromosomes cell will divide not once
but twice into a total of four cells in
each of the four cells has half the
total number of chromosomes that's what
we call the term haploid haploid cells
have half the total number of
chromosomes and in humans half of 46 is
23 so how does this process take place
how do what are the stages of
similarities and differences between
mitosis and meiosis that's what this
video is all about let's go ahead and
get started
so here we have two cells and the cell
on the top will eventually go through
mitosis and the cell on the bottom will
eventually go through meiosis right now
both of these cells are in interphase
interphase takes place prior to mitosis
and interphase takes place prior to
meiosis and what I want to do is first
count out the amount of chromatin DNA
strands of DNA that are in the nucleus
of these two cells and so I want to make
a note you know just to start in the top
cell we're starting with a cell that has
four strands of DNA one look at the
bottom cell in the bottom cell we also
see a cell that has four strands of DNA
and just so we don't forget that number
I'm going to go ahead and make a note of
it in the lower left hand corner and
that note is going to stay there the
whole time
as our silent reminder of how much DNA
was in each of these two cells at the
start so they each have four strands of
DNA called chromatin
well now that we're going to go through
this process what happens during the S
stage of interphase you can see the doin
a the DNA just duplicated the chromatin
strands duplicated and that happens in
the s stage of interphase which is prior
to mitosis now in the cell to the bottom
the same thing the cell to the bottom is
going to duplicate the strands of DNA
it's going to duplicate the chromatin
that happens during the S stage of
interphase which is prior to meiosis so
so far the two cells are setting up to
be fairly fairly similar to one another
well let's move on now we're going to
move on to the step known as prophase
and let's look at the cell on top it's
going to go through the prophase stage
of mitosis and so what happens is the
nucleus is going to dissolve and you see
the blue circle disappearing the next
thing that I want to note is look at the
bottom cell the bottom cell is also
going to lose its nucleus as it goes
through prophase number one of meiosis
in the top cell what I want to draw your
what I want to draw your attention to in
the top cell now is that the chromatin
the strands of chromatin that were just
duplicated are going to coil into
chromosomes I'll explain the P and the M
in just a moment in the bottom cell
prophase number one of meiosis really
the same thing is going to happen the
chromatin is going to coil into
chromosomes now I want to mention what
the P and what the M stands for the p
and this key is going to stay up here
for a little bit the P stands for
chromosomes that are paternal paternal
chromosomes or chromosomes you inherited
from your father the M stands for
maternal these are chromosomes you
inherited from your mother so notice how
we have a chromosome number one maternal
and a chromosome number one paternal M 1
and P 1 we in both cells there's also a
p1 which means excuse me in both cells
there's also a M 2 which means
chromosome number 2 from the mother and
there's also a p2
which means chromosome number two from
the father so M means maternal from the
mother P means paternal from the father
well let's move on with the process
so now that the chromosomes have formed
let's focus our attention on the bottom
cell prophase number one of meiosis
something else is going to happen
there's a process called synapses that's
about to happen in the animation this
only happens in prophase number one of
meiosis watch what happens during the
process called synapses the two
homologous chromosomes are paired up
with one another the two chromosome
number ones are paired up with one
another the maternal chromosome number
one and the paternal chromosome number
one the same thing happens with
chromosome number two the maternal and
the paternal chromosome number two's are
paired up with one another this pairing
up of homologous chromosomes is called
synapses this only happens during
prophase number one of meiosis and when
synapses is finished
uh this is what's created these
groupings of chromosomes here are called
a tetrad tetra is a prefix that means
four and the reason it's called a tetrad
is because you see the bracket in the
picture is around two chromosomes but
remember that one chromosome is made
from two chromatids
so if there's two chromosomes in a
tetrad that's a total of four chromatids
that's how they get their name this
process called synapses only occurs in
prophase number one of meiosis
okay so the next thing I want to mention
now that synapses has occurred the next
thing I want to mention is a process
known as crossing over and this only
happens in prophase number one of
meiosis watch this in crossing over
parts of the chromosomes are going to
swap with one another watch the
animation three-to-one parts of the
chromosomes swapped with one another
parts of the maternal and the paternal
chromosomes swapped with one another if
you missed it here it is again on the
other on the other tetrad so in crossing
over parts of the maternal chromosome
number one break away and connect with
the paternal chromosome number one so
the maternal and the paternal break off
parts of their chromosomes and they
recombine with one another this process
called crossing over shuffles up the
genetic gene combination just a little
bit and we'll see why that's relevant
near the end
so now when we go on to the next stage
called metaphase on the top let's look
at metaphase of mitosis in metaphase of
mitosis the four chromosomes in the
animation are randomly pulled to the
middle of the cell look at the bottom
animation now in metaphase number one of
meiosis those two tetrads are going to
be pulled randomly to the middle of the
cell and that's really all that takes
place remember who's pulling the
chromosomes here are those spindle
fibers and so let's move on to anaphase
so now the top again anaphase of mitosis
what happens next here it is what
happens next is the chromatids the
sister chromatids are pulled apart from
one another the spindle fibers will pull
one of the chromatids to the left the
other chromatid to the right so the
chromosome is ripped apart one chromatid
pulled to the left one chromatid pulled
to the right well now what about the
meiosis stage anaphase number one of
meiosis watch this the chromosomes are
pulled apart so the chromosomes are
still enjoyed see the tetrad two rapollo
part and the chromosomes are still
intact two entire complete chromosomes
were pulled to the right two entire
complete chromosomes were pulled to the
left so that's a bit of a distinction
that's different between the mitosis on
top and the meiosis on the bottom let's
move on into telophase so in the
telophase part of this present of this
project this presentation the process
known as cytokinesis is going to start
to split the side of the cytoplasm of
the cell and the two cells are going to
split in half you know sometimes
cytokinesis starts during anaphase but I
just threw it in here in the telophase
because this is kind of the final step
telophase is the final step of mitosis
so cytokinesis is going to split the one
cell into two when the cytoplasm divides
the next thing that's going to happen is
around those four bits of DNA that you
see is the nucleus is going to regrow
the nucleus offers protection for the
DNA that's inside
and finally the chromatids those four
chromatids are going to unwind back into
the linear strands of chromatin very
similar to how we started this this
video and that's really it that's really
the end result but look at the bottom
one we're going to see the bottom one's
not finished first of all in the
telophase number one of meiosis you just
saw cytokinesis split the two cells in
half well what happens next the nucleus
regrows and sometimes the nucleus does
not regrow but in
this animation we're going to show you
what happens when the nucleus does
regrow the nucleus regrows and that's
really it the chromosomes are not going
to unwind into chromatin so that's
really it telophase number one of
meiosis but we're not quite done because
this was just telophase number one
there's a round two of all this in just
a moment for meiosis
so when we look at the top sell the top
sells finished mitosis is over we
started with - excuse me we started with
one cell with four strands of DNA and we
ended with two cells with four strands
of DNA but now let's look at the bottom
we can focus on the bottom now prophase
number two of meiosis there is no
interphase number two just moves right
on into prophase number two and like it
says the nucleus is going to often
Reedy's all've until there it goes and
when we continue on when we continue on
to metaphase number two of meiosis the
chromosomes are going to be pulled to
the middle of the cell remember who is
pulling the chromosomes that would be
the spindle fibers so the chromosomes
are pulled to the middle of the cell
when we move on into anaphase number two
of meiosis now the chromatids are going
to be pulled apart so the chromatids get
pulled to opposite ends of the cell and
this animation of the chromatids one of
the chromatids went to the top the other
chromatid went to the bottom so the
chromosomes that were lined up in the
middle during metaphase the chromosomes
were ripped apart with one chromatid
going each direction and when we finally
move into telophase number two of
meiosis
well the cytoplasm is going to split
again during the process called
cytokinesis so the two cells have just
split into four the nucleus is going to
regrow but now it's going to regrow in
four cells and the last thing that's
going to happen here is the chromatids
are going to unwind back into the linear
version linear strands of DNA called
chromatin and that's really the end of
meiosis number two here so when you look
at the end result what we finished with
is four haploid cells
so just to wrap up this and kind of give
this quick conclusion here if you notice
I want to point your attention to the
Box in the upper left hand corner when
we started this video there were four
strands of DNA in the one cell at the
top well let's count up the strands of
DNA now the new cells the two new cells
on top look at that
four strands of DNA in the cell on the
left and four strands of DNA in the cell
on the right so the cell started with
four strands of DNA and the two that are
created each have four strands of DNA as
well and not only that but both cells
are identical they each have two fully
black strands of chromatin they each
have two fully red strands of chromatin
the cells are identical to one another
well now let's focus our attention to
the one on the bottom so the cells on
the bottom just went through meiosis but
remember at the start they each had four
strands of DNA in them let's count up
the strands of DNA now the new cells
have half the amount of chromatin as
they did from the start look at that
that cell only has two the cell in the
upper right hand corner only has two
strands of chromatin the cell in the
lower left only has two strands of
chromatin the cell on the lower right
only has two strands of chromatin so the
cell at the beginning had four strands
of DNA but these cells only have two
well that's because these are haploid
cells created by meiosis another thing I
want to point out is that each cell is
genetically unique each cell has a
unique mixture of red and black strands
of chromatin because the process called
crossing over which took place way back
in prophase number one so that is one of
the unique the major unique differences
of meiosis which does not happen during
mitosis
and this really will conclude this video
right here so the cells on top the cells
on top started to go through my went
through mitosis and so cells that go
through my ptosis will start diploid and
n diploid but the cells on the bottom
cells that will go through meiosis will
start diploid but at the end they're
going to have half the amount of
chromatin and they're going to end
haploid so that's it that's the updated
video I hope you like it better than the
original one I tried to be a little more
thorough by adding crossing over so I
hope you learned good luck in your
understanding of mitosis versus meiosis